investing is an infinite game jeff bezos
he doesn't walk around saying look how
rich i am if anything he says look at
the amazing company that i've built
use the reading for what it's good for
but use phone conversations for what
they're good for and reach out to the
right people it was a great great hack
what's up believe nation if you're
interested in success building wealth
and pursuing happiness along the way
then i have a great interview for you
today's guest is guy speer a very
successful investor who's known for
three things one he's had lunch with
warren buffett
two he shared countless of insights and
value in his book the education of a
value investor which i highly recommend
reading
and three he also manages money himself
nine figures in assets for individuals
helping grow their capital with his
aquarium fund capital so if you're
interested in the three things i shared
at the beginning make sure you sit back
relax and enjoy the interview i've been
following your work your interviews i've
read your book really diving into you
know
manesh you
charlie munger warren buffett you know
the tribe you could say and so i guess
as a starting question i want to go into
investing performance and i'm curious to
know what key elements
for you
have have led to your success
you know um and thank you jeremy thank
you for having me really i feel
honored i don't have you know
people people talk about it as an omaha
number
our number is like high teens at least
for a very long period of time and i've
been going now a long period of time and
i actually do have returns that are
better than the s p
but not by a lot and like i've
annualized after fees at about 10 p.r
which is which is not like super
spectacular
but it is i would tell you that if you
do the compounding if you just put up a
spreadsheet and see what happens if you
grow at 10 p.r for like 23 years
it's pretty amazing actually at any
level of starting assets you end up with
some extraordinary results
uh exactly what goes into it i mean i
think that every single person's
starting condition
starting position is so different and
you cannot compare
where different people start from so
everyone is on a very very personal
journey
and they each bring some advantages and
some disadvantages so if you take manish
he he had sold a business
and um he started investing money the
proceeds of that business that he'd sold
i think that one of the advantages that
that gave him was that it was entirely
his money that he was investing
and that's a very but that was very good
in my case
i had not sold a business i was
interested in investing and i just left
investment banking and
i had my father come along and say
you're clearly interested in this why
don't you try managing some of this
money but so i already from the starting
gate
had a very very different orientation it
wasn't my money it wasn't a business
that i'd built
that i had the proceeds of and so and
then even then there's the personal
aspects of it so some people in my shoes
would have gambled like mad
and i went in the opposite direction i
was just
unbelievably scared because i knew
exactly what proportion of his net worth
that represented which was pretty much
all of it so i went into super super
conservative mode what's my point to you
is that
when you're looking at track records
there is so much that has gone into that
track record that you just don't see and
will never know in a certain way
and uh
so but what goes into it i mean i think
my point is to make
every single individual
who is
working at investing and is developing a
track record to forgive themselves and
understand
that so much of what goes into that
track record and what that track record
becomes
has got
as much to do with their starting
conditions as anything else
i would tell you that i i was never
shooting for the stars i was never
trying to have the best returns because
i'd figured out that even with
okay returns so long as i could stay at
it
i'd be
doing very very well
provided i could stay in the game for
long enough and
there's a book uh by simon sinek called
the infinite game and there's a book by
a guy called james cast called finite
and infinite games and
the idea
behind both those books is that
investing is an infinite game in that
the very worst thing that you can do is
to do something that would get you taken
out
will get you sent off the pitch you know
um so if you're a
you're a football player if you're a
soccer player and you foul the other
team it doesn't take you off the pitch
for good
but um there are some things that you
can do investing which take you off the
pitch for good
and so you just want to more than
getting really really high returns is
that you just want to avoid those
mistakes that take you off the pitch and
then somebody else has another really
good way of putting it it's like
in life you want to avoid zero so it
doesn't matter
any number however big
if you multiply it by zero
is zero
and so you really want to be careful
that you're not engaging in any zero so
hang gliding is tantamount to asking god
to give you a zero because it because
very simple errors and it happens all
the time to hang gliders but you know a
wing suit wingsuit flying those are all
potential zeros right there but in the
investing world it's shocking how
some really really smart people
who really ought to know better and
you know i mean the the um
long-term capital management may have
been before you were interested in
investing but these guys had not just
phds they had a nobel prize winner on
their in their management and they
basically
they risked to zero and guess what the
xero came along
and so when it comes to me
what i figured out was that if i just
and it's a kind of a charlie munger
thing of inversion if i just avoided the
biggest mistakes of investing
and i could get somewhat of a decent
return for myself and my investors that
would be a pretty good life
and so that's kind of where i've been
focused on
and i
there was one time in 1998
that it's the only time that the fund
that i managed was leveraged by ten
percent
and when i look back
i mean that's nothing compared to the
guy from our cheegos levitt i don't know
how many times and your interest i was
yesterday
visiting credit suisse you know the very
trading floor from which some of that
credit was allocated
but even at 10 leverage you just don't
know how the world could react to
something and suddenly you find yourself
without a fund and
jeremy it happens to the smartest and
nicest people
so so far i've avoided it and i have
every intent of avoiding it over the
course of the rest of my life
i don't know is that's a long and
rambling answer i hope i gave you some
kind of
insight and response that was worthwhile
for you and the listeners no that was
that was perfect in terms of you know i
know there's a quote where this isn't
like 100 iq game where 140 iq doesn't
beat 100 iq
um
so
yeah it's uh
it's
the practical steps
long-term patience and
um yeah i guess in terms of some of
those pitfalls
do you think people who are out there
trying to
you know build wealth and
knowing that compounding has to play a
role in it that
you know even just setting a target of
okay i would love to make
if i could make 12 per year for 23 years
like set or 15 like setting a target
like that are you already setting
yourself up for failure uh potentially
yes and i hope you don't mind i just
discovered i can make myself
that's kind of better isn't it perfect i
saw you kind of react as you in any case
i don't think you're setting yourself up
for failure but
um
you're you're
and it's who might say you're going
about it the wrong way uh is there so
many contradictions in the world of
finance in which
um
and i think that in in many ways the
world has got contradictions in that it
seems to me jeremy that
the way to get to things is by the
indirect route i've keep finding that
the direct route doesn't doesn't get you
where you want to go and just to give
you you know i love talking about drunks
and bars but
um
so you know in in the
if you're trying to get the girl
so if you walk up to her in in the
social setting and say wow you're you
look absolutely awesome maybe we could
sit down and talk for a while and if
things work out maybe we could go home
together develop a relationship and then
maybe one day we might get married but
meanwhile you're just unbelievably hot
and i'm sure you're also really
interested interesting and can we just
get to know each other
that would be a very direct approach
which would go to the core of at least
what would have been in my mind
at that age
when that was going on for me
and but by contrast you know even just
like oh you have a beautiful sounding
name or would you like to go look at my
stamp collection
are you interested in stamps i'm very
interested in stance you know would you
like to see
that indirect approach somehow
uh
yields far better results and i think
that you know so it's just conflating
two things the what we want to do is
build wealth
but when we try and take the direct
approach we're taking the risk you know
you you take that approach with a girl
that i just described and maybe
you know one in one and a half you know
99 100 girls will slap you in the face
and tell you where to get off
but the indirect approach is just going
to get you better results so i'm not
saying it's absolutely wrong
but um
and then i i so i think
another analogy for me is
that i found really useful
i don't know how to fly a plane but when
i was younger i took flying lessons
mainly to please my father who's an avid
pilot
and i i discovered this really
interesting thing when they're teaching
you to land a plane when the when the
airplane comes close to the ground
a beginner pilot wants to kind of look
down wants to look over the side of the
cockpit to see how close you are to the
ground and what they teach you is you
need
to kind of like
watch for the horizon to come up in your
peripheral vision because it turns out
if you look over the side of the cockpit
you're not going to fly the plane
straight and level and you're going to
have a horrible landing and potentially
even crash the plane so
so the idea is that sometimes the most
important you've got to keep your
eye fixed on the long term goal and let
these kind of things come into one's
peripheral vision and so
actually having high returns is an
intermediate target it's not actually
what we're looking for it's kind of
looking over the side of the cockpit and
can lead to great terrible results
what we're actually looking for is a
better life
and what what would it take for us to
live a better life and
focus on those things and growing wealth
is a part of that and so i'll just give
you one example rather than staying in
ethereal theory which drives my whole
family nuts i can tell you my wife and
my three children
but um you know so charlie munger says
the best way to get success is to
deserve it so
rather than trying to earn high returns
why not
work on becoming the kind of investor
that management teams would love to have
on their shareholder list and so you
know if
if i do more work to have great insights
into industries and companies so that
management teams seek me out or i get
develop a reputation and i'm by the way
nowhere near a great story on this yet
but i hope to become they say wow you've
got guys peers investor that's fantastic
you must be getting so many insights
what a wonderful investor to have
i still want to build wealth at the
highest rate but i'm focusing on a
better on a better goal something that's
closer to the horizon or you know i mean
i was listening to podcast
by
william greene um the author of this
book uh richer wiser happier and he was
expressing this idea of
the best way to get good friends is to
be a good friend
you know the best way to get success is
to deserve success and so i think that
those kinds of
you know another one would be jeremy
it's not actually about how high a
return you earn
but simply making sure that you
underspend whatever it is that you do
own so there are some personalities
where they can are they very high
earners and they're very successful
investors potentially but but they can't
help increasing
their appetite
commensurate with the rate at which
their wealth is increasing and they may
live in constant financial stress as a
result
whereas if you just kind of reverse that
and make sure you live well within your
means that's a far better actually
that's an intermediate goal but it's a
very simple litmus so
developing the right
long-term
horizon-like
things to focus on i think it can make
an enormous difference and i would tell
you i know you're nodding your head and
it sounds obvious but
i look at myself and i realize that
there are certain periods in my life
where i was just focusing on the wrong
thing as an enormous waste of resources
and all i had to do was refocus
where my intention was going you know
it's another forgive me you
the listener you can see that jeremy's
just listening he's not kind of shaking
his he's not he's not stopping me from
talking so i'll continue talking there's
another analogy from driving which is
really really interesting so
if you ever learn to drive on a skid pan
where you know they kind of cover the
they make up the surface very slippery
so kind of the car easily spins out of
control which is an enormous amount of
fun by the way
but um there's this weird thing that you
tend to go the car will tend to steer
even though the rear wheels have spun
out and it's not entirely in control
you the car tends to go where you look
so what they teach you in terms of
getting the car back into control and
getting to where you want to go is look
where you want to go and of course the
first thing that happens when the car
spins out of control is what a lot of
people do is they look where they're
afraid to go
so if you're afraid to hit the tree and
you're just looking at the tree it's
very likely that you'll hit the tree or
far more likely whereas if you look to
see where you'd like the car to get to
you're far more likely to get there but
you know i've spent 23 years or 25 years
in the investment world and i'm i'm
blown away at how many people for
example get into fights
and you kind of say well why is this a
long term why is this going to get you
to where you want to get to
and the answer will be oh but they have
wronged me and therefore i have to and
therefore and suddenly they've kind of
bogged down in a rabbit hole basically
but i'll give you back the mic because
who knows where the hell is
jeremy
no and i i love hearing those stories
the viewers you know the less
interruptions and the more i can squeeze
out of you is perfect so thank you for
those um
but you just realized jeremy that this
is very very different to my family who
will just shut me down so quickly they'd
be snoring
you know they'd be fast asleep or they
would have left the room i will have
been talking to pure thin air you know
oh no no stories
yes this is this is gold so thank you
um
in regards to
yeah and then you know nodding my head
it is something where like i'm nodding
it because i i know i've personally just
thought about oh if i could make this
return on this money that
you know i would be i'd be financially
free and not have to answer to anyone
and you know trying to
get that out of my head is
and just focus on not losing money as
the
the primary thing um
i guess in regards to especially right
now
when just
it can seem very hard to maybe find
ideas and and find investments
how do you stay in the areas of what you
know
and don't try and convince yourself that
you're you understand this
and you're going down a path where
you don't know what you don't know
oh
and i'm curious how you deal with that
because yeah exactly
and and i i love answering it's kind
enough the listener loves answering but
exactly that's a really hard question
and to ask the questions to answer it
there are no easy answers there's
nothing obvious and so you've asked a
very very good question and i just want
to acknowledge that
because really good questions are really
difficult to answer
and or can be really difficult that is a
really good question and
the mere fact that you're asking
yourself the question means that you're
reaching for an answer
and in some cases i think simply
reaching for an answer is about as good
as you can get
so you're stretching yourself in the
right direction and so that's a
fantastic start because there'll be some
people out there who are like i'm the
world's greatest expert on
dot dot dot you don't realize it and
even my brain doesn't realize it and you
kind of say
yeah they're probably going to they
they're going to have a come a cropper
sooner rather than later because they
clearly don't know enough about it
um
i think that
the most helpful thing for you is
that
there are no silver bullets as best i
can tell or
jeremy if there are silver bullets i
haven't found them send them my way
and um
again from william green's book and i
don't remember who he's quoting but he
there's a wonderful phrase that he uses
multiple times called the aggregation of
marginal gains
and um
you know it's it so so so this is
actually super fun and interesting so
when the
the problem with so much of business
biography
is that it needs to tell a story
otherwise it's not going to sell
and so you have to torture reality
to some or greater or lesser degree in
order to tell the interesting story
but the interesting story that's going
to sell your book may not reflect the
reality so
the guy who's who's writing about sam
walton wants to tell an interesting
story about sam walton but as best i can
tell in so many businesses
it wasn't one silver bullet they you had
a personality like sam walton or reed
hastings or warren buffett
who is spending
his or i should say her although my last
three examples did not include is she
they're spending their whole lives
trying to find any
gain any opportunity to improve and it's
when you pull all of those together
that you get uh some overarching result
and so when it comes to
um
you know sort of
to resume right to restate your question
thinking for the long term and playing
within one circle of competence
uh you know the aggregation of marginal
gains for me comes from some of the
following kinds of thinking so
um
i i first of all the very profound bias
against acting on the portfolio
so
it's not like if an idea is one percent
better than what i've got into in the
portfolio then i'll make the switch
it may have to be you know 200 percent
better it's got to get have a huge and
meaningful and that's just a conscious
choice
that i'm not going to ask unless there's
a very f because i know that
the world is so noisy and my brain is so
noisy and there are so many reasons why
i might end up acting and in retrospect
realize that i was just i was reacting
to noise and not signal that i want that
threshold to be really really high you
know in in the audio world you have kind
of a low-pass filter which kind of cuts
out all the so you want and you can make
that filter extraordinarily high you
know in a certain way warren buffett
says wake me up when there's another
financial crisis
actually poor warren buffett he was
ready
for the crisis of last year but the fed
stepped in so quickly he didn't have the
chance to act it was super frustrating
for him but so you can now go back to
sleep and when there's another financial
crisis he'll wake up again his threshold
for acting
is
extraordinarily high
and then
you know i think that i kind of see
my areas of expertise or or superior
knowledge to the extent that i have any
as kind of like an archipelago of
islands
and
i'm not saying that i shouldn't from
time to time do a hop to some completely
other set of islands a completely
different continent and see what the
world looks like from that
but i think that in general moving
around
sort of like the areas and territories
i'm familiar with and to allow um
knowledge to unfold slowly in my
definition of the boundaries of that
knowledge to unfold slowly
is
i think something that actually i would
say i consciously do so i know
i know what's home territory for me and
for what it's worth jeremy home
territory is not it's not so much that i
have
very special expertise in those areas
it's more that i've spent enough time in
the world to know that i'm not going to
be blindsided in those areas so some
industries move very very slowly even if
the companies are losing competitiveness
it's going to happen at a slow pace and
or if they're gaining competitiveness
it's going to happen to slow pace and so
it's not so much that i know more it's
that the playing field is more level for
everyone who wants to play there then
none of them are going to get blindsided
but so that that's just a couple of ways
in which i deal with a very very
valuable and valid challenge that you
just posed but i'll tell you something
that i was at a conference in dubai
i heard an absolutely spectacular guy
speak um if you get him on your show it
would be his name is dennis hong
and uh he did something he he
helped me to figure out something that
he said helped me to understand that
so much of what is really interesting
that's going on in the global economy
right now is happening surprise surprise
i mean it's not it's it's pretty
freaking obvious so forgive me you know
you some of you people listening and say
geez you only figured this out
but they're happening around you know
anderson's horowitz software is eating
the world but also it's the realization
not just any software
it's
those guys that sequoia fund anderson
horowitz and three or four other funds
that are really got extraordinary
insights
combined with extraordinary access to
talent and knowledge and capital
and so
you know i've decided that i'm going to
invest more of my time really getting to
know all of the people in that industry
and finding out how they think and what
they think about
and so that's kind of me jumping to a
completely different
kind of continent to where i've
inhabited if you think about i've
inhabited
credit rating agencies and
consumer goods and brands and maybe some
luxury brands i'm going to a completely
different area so i'm going to just kind
of spend time in that part and see what
i learn
and maybe i'll develop an expertise but
maybe i won't so
and you're just playing
you know the analogy that i've used is
drunks and bars
and you know assume you're a drunk in a
bar and set the bar up so so you know
what is that in practice that means that
you're spending a lot of time
setting up the way the bar looks and
where the drinks are and whether
alcoholic and non-alcoholic so when i
say i'm going let's say to investigate
that world yeah it's just playing what i
mean what an incredible job i have that
i can spend vast amounts of time
exploring and thinking and not taking
any action at all
and so yeah i'm just
you know but you would say just playing
and i'm not saying that it's any more
than just playing but you know albert
einstein was just playing when he
figured out theory of relativity so
sometimes play is the best way to figure
stuff out if you like
i'm curious uh in terms of how your days
typically go how much is spent
um reading versus thinking yeah i don't
spend enough time reading
you've got me if you you won't be able
to see and i'm definitely not
um
uh taking that camera off where it's
sitting
on my monitor but the other side of this
monitor is a flat desk
with no um
with no i don't look into a commute
computer monitor there's not that to
distract me and i try to spend as much
time on that side of the desk as
possible and then in the room next door
just through that wall there there's
my famous library which i love and i
don't spend enough time in that library
as well so
um
and and i have
as i think many of us do a sort of a
love-hate
relationship with my
computer because it's so extraordinarily
valuable but i try we've got a really
high-speed printer i love that printer
i'll print stuff out and then i try and
convince myself to go to the other side
of my desk and read on that side of the
desk and i'm at my happiest i find that
it energizes me i find that the
electronic screen while it's very very
useful drains me
but one thing that i've found has been
i believe it will be very very helpful
actually is that i use a piece of
software
called rome research
that
i really enjoy it's kind of i think that
from a tech perspective there's nothing
that special about it although i've
probably just insulted the founder group
by saying that
but it's got these bi-directional links
and so you can kind of slice through
your thoughts and it's an amazing tool
for creative thought and i find that
when i'm browsing all sorts of websites
what's really helpful is to close those
websites and to make myself feel better
about closing them i'll close it but
i'll copy and paste the link into rome
and write two words about why that
website was interesting to me and so i
can always find my way back to it and
that's kind of helps me to keep that
you talked i think about an endless
scroll
and websites i guess provide you with
endless clicks
and in a sense
so
um but then you know just to come down
to it
yeah i mean i hope you don't mind the
facetiousness of the answer in which i
say
how much you asked how much time do you
spend reading and i say not enough and
um
and then the only other thing or there's
plenty more to say is
there's an infinite practically an
infinite amount of material to read
and so
one has to exercise very
uh efficient or as efficient triage as
possible so
what am i reading and why when i get a
thick 10k
am i going to the balance sheet first
and we're going to the business
description fast
and um i actually think that
i mean there's no but it's interesting
so there's an argument for
saying that we spend too much time
reading
that i spend too much time reading so
i'm not going to read i mean every year
20 000 books are published
and uh you know i have this goal to read
at least some of the world's classics
around five years ago i started reading
things like victor hugo's les miserables
and
warren peace and jane austen's novels
and they're just fiction reading fiction
and then i realized that there are these
literary review newspapers like the
london review of books
and the literary review in the new york
times review of books and they're kind
of providing meta knowledge they're kind
of telling you it's not the same as
reading the book but they're giving you
kind of like guide posts around the
books that are being published and
what's around and actually i'm having a
lot of fun reading just book reviews
and so that metal knowledge around
uh opportunities in the corporate
landscape is not a dumb thing to do
but it it's a question of who one talks
to you and
so the person who says hey jeremy i just
bought this amazing stock you to buy it
too it's going to go up tomorrow here
i'll send you the latest press release
it's probably somebody that you don't
want to spend too much time talking to
but somebody who says you know i'm
really fascinated i've been thinking
about the wix model and i think it's got
elements to it which is just like stripe
you know and then you can go well
in what ways is wix like stripe
and by the way i took i took those two
examples straight out of thin air and i
would tell you i don't think
i don't think i've spent enough time
having those kinds of conversation
and just to give you another analogy in
dubai my wife and i we went and spent a
couple of days out in the desert in an
oasis
and i think that
much of the investment world is a value
trap
and um
you know it's kind of like the desert
and where we want to go is the aurases
and when you're an inno an oasis you
know what other oases look like and you
kind of want to go from oasis to oasis
but if you've been in the desert
you don't know what the oasis looks like
and uh it may be that reading to go back
to the investing is not the fastest way
to get the oases it may be that what you
want to do is do what my friend marcelo
limo is doing right now is attending a
conference on solana
in lima not in lima in um
his name is marcelo lima he's attending
a conference on solana in portugal and
because all of that you know i wrote in
my book somewhere that
you know all
all the knowledge that
is really important we're far more
likely to learn it from human
individuals and i wrote something along
the lines of getting the right
individuals into your life
maybe the most important thing that we
do what's my long that's a very long way
of saying jeremy it's nice of you to ask
how much i read and there's i'm not
going to go wrong by saying read as much
as you can
but there's also an argument for saying
put the book down and go talk to
somebody pick up the phone
you know combine those two kinds of
knowledge acquisition
use the reading for what it's good for
but use phone conversations for what
they're good for and reach out to the
right people
and you know and and for what it's worth
and i don't think i've been very good at
this
is
if i just you know if i reach out to
um you name it
jim o'shaughnessy who has a very famous
and successful podcast called i believe
invest with the best pat o'shaughnessy
and i say hey what do you think of this
or that company
i'm not sure what kind of response i'd
get i don't even know if he knows who i
am
but
if i reach out to him with a company
that i know he's discussed and might
have in his portfolio with some
interesting thoughts and ideas and
research that may not point him to any
firm conclusions but it's definitely
helpful
and he might pick up the phone and and
then it's kind of like
he might say oh if you like this
business these are three other
businesses that you should certainly
look at and or if you like this business
i can tell you that the guy who's the
real expert who's thought about these
things the most is this and that person
and maybe you want to talk to him so my
point is combining
reading
with writing
with conversations
and i think that that actually that's a
world and an approach to
doing investment research that is
it's new actually it's still being
developed and unfolded and and i'm
actually jeremy very behind on the curve
of it on it there are some people who
are way ahead on it
but hopefully i'll catch up i'm not dumb
uh yeah i guess in
going back to bouncing of ideas of
other people i know you know warren and
charlie have each other and
i know you bounce ideas off of monesh
and he does for you and
um i guess
that is a crucial thing where if you
know you're starting out or not even
just investing it you know for people to
you know even in school maybe to expand
their network
more so as the most important thing
is something you know even as a
introverted myself i need to maybe do
more
personally
just to tell you a couple of stories
there that
i think are helpful to anybody listening
to this so
monash is friends with charlie munger
and uh it's um i i can't say i'm deeply
envious
because i get to have a front row seat
on that friendship and that's lovely and
i'm very very happy for my friend monish
but i would be
lying to you if i didn't say that i
would love also to be friends with
charlie and
for one reason or another charlie has
space in his life for monash and he
doesn't have space in his life for me
which is you know the guy's 97 years old
i think we should cut him a little bit
of slack he's glad to pick his friend so
no issues there but monish um at one
event he brought me to charlie munger
and he sat me down and he says to
charlie charlie
you know this is the guy that i talked
to about stocks and i'm sitting
and charlie pay i don't know if i don't
know exactly if it's a backhanded
compliment or he looks at me he looks at
one and she says and and i've already
joked no this that's what happens
i say you know you know charlie i think
that monash would do just as well if i
was just a furry animal in a cage an
inanimate furry animal in a cage
you know i don't actually have to be a
real human in fact i don't even have to
talk back
and charlie not charlie i believe the
way i remember it was was in deep
agreement with that idea and
um
so
the this idea of having the right person
to bounce ideas off is obviously very
very important
but it's i think that we could be
surprised by
um exactly what function they provide
exactly how smart they need to be
exactly what input they give
and
it's all about creating that space to
think carefully and independently about
what you're about to do what you're
about
not to do
and
and i think that my experience of that
friendship with monash which i deeply
value is that
you know different different sort of
dyads
combinations of two minds thinking about
things
unfold in different ways so
monash has a far higher risk tolerance
than me
and he's willing to do some stuff
for example it's no secret that he has
significant investments i believe in
turkey
and um
that's probably going to work out very
very well for him
and
i would um
i'd be carrying in a cave every single
day of my life if i had even
one percent of my portfolio in turkey
not quite but it'd just make me deeply
uncomfortable so while it's still fun to
talk for example about investments in
turkey to manage obviously because i'm
not invested in them beyond unlikely to
invest
i i can provide less value added to
monash than
uh somebody who's on the ground looking
at those companies in turkey so
i think that what's my last point before
i throw the ball back into your call is
not to be too fixated on the model that
warren and charlie have given us
the the the idea of sharing your ideas
with others bouncing your ideas of other
people with whom one has a good rapport
and who provide valuable insights is
definitely a good thing
but don't i my experiences don't feel
like you have to restrict it to one
person
you know be smart about how you choose
those people i think that
um
i think that you know the the cloning
monitors talked about cloning and
obviously cloning is a good thing but
the real rub is what to clone and what
not to clone you know nobody's telling
me that i should wear at the same shot
size as charlie munger you know
nobody's saying that i should eat peanut
brittle exactly the same way he does
so some things are definitely not worth
cloning and don't go to the core of it
but and obviously there are examples
that are trite and easy to pull out of a
hat but some examples are not so obvious
and easy and i think that you know it
doesn't have to be one person no it
doesn't have to be one person but you
want to cultivate relationships
i want to cultivate relationships that
make
that lead to knowledge and not every
relationship a a vehement debate over a
topic
could actually you know the expression
is there's more heat than light you know
so you don't i don't think that i want
to have vehement debates
over over um investment ideas i want to
have
nuanced explorations with my friends
yeah well thank you for that yeah it's
um i i will say um just as like more of
an acknowledgement not a question
um
your book education of a value investor
i just have it right here for anyone i
highly recommend watching it uh or start
reading it
the second book i ever read in my entire
life
so very very was very interesting to
just go into indigo's which is barnes
noble but canada version
and pick that up
um and i think the most impactful thing
from that book was in terms of
trying to find expanding and finding
more people who
um i i could include into my life was
actually the writing handwritten notes
aspect of it
i see you started doing that
yeah and that helped me a lot with uh
help getting me to uh where i am today
in business with evan and and people
like evan so it's been i just want to
acknowledge and thank you for that and
you know highly recommend people read
that book because
if you're an introvert like me it's
it was a great great hack just so you
know i'm i first of all i'm so delighted
that it helped you
and um yeah i was about to say it's the
ultimate strategy for an introvert
because you just don't have to reach out
and glandhand people you can just write
you know and i found that
extraordinarily liberating and
and i've learned so much from it because
and i found that in the process of
writing the notes i'm far more self
conscious of what i'm doing and what i'm
trying to say
than if i'm you know in some cocktail
party trying to react to what somebody
just said and so i think that one my
relationship to the people i was writing
to
became more nuanced and it became more
i had there was more depth and color to
it because i'd really thought about who
they were and i'd given myself so this
kind of weird thing that you're writing
i'm writing a thank you note but in the
same time in the process of writing the
thank you note i'm thinking through what
this what this person really means to me
and and i i'm delighted that it had that
impact on you i would tell you that i
get some interns and we regularly have
interns here who get it right away and
they produce a large number of notes and
i
for some interns it's like bringing you
know it's just impossible waterproof
i cannot get them to see and i i've
actually in a certain way given up
because
i kind of get them to see how exciting
it is that when you send off
a bevy of 20 30 notes
because you just have attended event
that's kind of like
that's your future waiting to happen and
you just don't know how the future will
unfold who will respond who won't who
will reach out who won't so
yeah
yeah it's uh the mystery of it too is
the anticipation of one out of 50 right
uh
yeah it's in a certain way it's with
doing those kinds of things that my life
really really got started and and i
suddenly started living in a life in
which i was
in um in joyful anticipation of what
surprise is going to show up as a result
of the seeds that i've planted and in a
broader sense that and and you should
know that in the book i write about
thank you notes it's again it's a
distortion of the story in order to be
able to tell
in order to keep the reader entertained
because the broader idea is to keep
planting seeds
planting seeds for your for for future
results to come in in a direction that
you want them to come so you know you
don't plant seeds in a garden you never
want to walk in but you look at your
garden you say well what kind of plants
would i like to see and then plant seeds
that might
actually grow and then then what
happened to me is that i got and this is
goes back to one of your very first
questions which was
um how about you know should we one
focus on the returns and my response was
well maybe one shouldn't focus on the
returns and i started planting seeds
with the hope of certain kinds of
rewards
and you know sort of hope you know for
example sending thank you cards to
people who might invest with me in the
hope that they might develop the idea
that they ought to invest with me
but as as results started coming back
i
my goal came became just to plant seeds
with the expectation of
the excitement of knowing what rewards
would come in as a result of that and
not caring too much which ones they were
and that was a that was a kind of like a
little growth bump for me because
obviously it's a more enlightened life
that way
and um i remember
you know the some of the first thank you
notes and some of the first gifts i sent
out
there's there's a few sort of like
rookie mistakes if you like so one of
the rookie mistakes is to send something
off and then two days later to call the
recipient and say well did you receive
it did you receive it and what and what
and what and then like yeah i received
it and could you please leave me alone
who are you weirdo you know
and um
to get to the place where there are so
many things that i'm i i'm confident
that the process of doing them will lead
to good results but i'm not expecting
any one of them to
it's a kind of a it took me a while to
get there i was i was doing those first
thank you notes for some very venal
and self-interested and selfish reasons
that i grew through the process of doing
it so
i i appreciate that you're on that
journey and if you ever decide to write
something about how it's impacted you
i'll be really fascinated to read and
see i will i will definitely be sending
that your way
what i you know for what it's worth um
something that comes up for me is that
um i think that in many ways so much of
these so we as a
our culture has become so disconnected
from ancient texts
and so we're kind of discovering you
know guy spear writes his book or
there's uh somebody i know dory clark
who recently wrote a book called the art
of the long game and the phrase that
comes up to me that i'm going to totally
butcher from the bible is
the old testament cast your breads on
your wall on the waters and it will come
back to you which is exactly that idea
but i think that we are so cut off
in so many ways as a civilization from
those ancient texts that we find new
prophets or people repeat old wisdoms
and they look like they're this great
prophet whereas actually they don't some
of them don't even realize
we don't even realize that what we're
doing is actually repeating wisdoms that
are sitting there in the ancient texts
if we would just open them and take a
look at them with an open mind
yeah i see a lot of influencer quotes of
seneca
you know it's just oh okay
i guess one thing i admire most about
you
is in the pursuit of building wealth and
and having have built wealth is you know
following your instagram
you know it's clear that you
you you're not just
work 24 7 accumulation of money like a
lot of people are out there
you know it seems you you clearly have a
life um
on a bicycle
on a bicycle around cappuccinos
cappuccinos family and i'm just curious
to know um
within your within your fund
uh how have you structured it so that
you are able to
maybe not the word balance but
portion off
so you're not you know stuck in this
only pursuit of money and
yeah well one thing i should tell you is
that i i think i've figured out twitter
pretty well
thanks to david perrault i don't if you
know him and a guy called matt kobach
and also a guy called thiago forte
david peralta has online videos on
youtube basically here's how to do
twitter and he really taught me
um
i didn't have to pay him anything you
know i didn't do any of his courses and
i'm really grateful because it kind of
changed my twitter world in a major way
um
i haven't figured out instagram i don't
fully i'm not entirely sure that i'm
comfortable with any of the posts that i
do
and i post there and and because it's
kind of fun to do and it's fun to get a
reaction and
i really enjoy taking the photographs of
me when i've gone cycling or the strava
pics or the strava maps and then i kind
of try and get some nice bright colors
there and put them up there there's
another level in which i i really don't
know why i'm doing it or who i'm doing
it for
but um
i think that
here's i i don't know if you or any of
the listeners plan to set up a fund i
really
underestimated
how important it was to get the
relationship with my investors right
and
there's a book
by a professor at harvard business
school called
different
and it's by young me moon
and
she basically talks about
businesses that say no
firmly but confidently say no to the
client
and you think well the client's always
right you never say no to the client why
would you say no to the client and
just to give you briefly some examples
you know costco
they kind of say well
the only way we'll let you into the
store is if you become a member
and somebody shows up and say i don't
want to become a member i just want to
go see if you've got xyz products and if
you got it i'll buy it you know the
answer is no you you've got to become a
member we only want to deal with members
there's an example of a business saying
quietly but firmly no
another example in her book is ikea
you know where the client shows up the
imaginary client and says
you know i'd like this in the color
purple and like it assembled in my home
and the answer is no it comes in green
blue and yellow and you can get it flat
packed period end of story
and so
by
by telling the customer
setting yourself up in a certain way and
telling the customer exactly who you
desire what you want to deliver and how
you're designed to deliver it and if
you're not willing to accept
that state of affairs you're probably
the wrong customer for this business
is something that helps those businesses
that i've just described function
extremely well and that perhaps even at
an optimal level and so there's another
another thought that comes up in the
management literature and business which
is every now and then you've got to fire
your clients
so you know if you've got the wrong
client so what's what what's my point
um
i've learned that i can have a quiet
happy
well-regulated life
if i tell my clients
you know ikea style or costco style
here's the deal
you lock up your money you tie up your
money with me for at least a year and a
time at a time
and i know that's a significant
commitment but basically if you want a
bank account i'm not it i want you to be
tying your money up for at least a year
with me
and the quid pro quo is
i'm not going to charge you anything as
a management fee i'm going to only going
to charge you a performance fee so
that that kind of
not compromising on the time of the
investment you've got to tie your money
up with me for a year or more otherwise
you're at the wrong place is what gives
me the peace of mind it's not that i
actually find it interesting
i was observing somebody who
is set up in such a way where
technically all of the money could be
pulled
from uh one week to the next
because it's kind of like not quite
daily it's not daily liquidity well many
mutual funds have daily liquidity
so in theory you could lose all of your
assets very quickly that puts the
investment manager under an enormous
amount of stress
and it so it's got nothing to do with
kind of like do i like the investor or
have i met him for coffee or he's a
member of my family or we went to the
same university or speaks the same way i
do it's about just selecting for that
very simple idea of you know ikea
there's nothing wrong with buying
chippendale beautiful antique wooden
furniture there's nothing wrong there's
a furniture manufacturer just across the
border here in germany from near to the
swiss border with germany
called vitra they make the most
beautiful furniture
i am a great client for vitra i love
their furniture i'm not a good client
for ikea that doesn't bother ikea
you know and ikea's selecting for their
customers so long story short the reason
to the extent that you're seeing me
living a full or and or fulfilled life
it really started when i started to
understand
what kind of investors i'm looking for
and then not
not just pining in the fields for them
but
structuring the funds that i could
attract them
you know warren buffett says
it doesn't matter whether you run a
mcdonald's or a three-star michelin
restaurant it's just that the menu and
everything that attracts you know you
can't if somebody comes expecting
mcdonald's walks into a three-star
admission restaurant ain't gonna work
and vice versa so i became more aligned
with what i was looking for
and that is the source that really is
the source
of any kind of calmness and living a
full life
um i would tell you that i i don't fully
understand
those people who are already rich
who are hankering after yet more money
uh i think that i i didn't understand it
in warren buffett for the longest time
until i finally understood that in in
the case of warren buffett
it really is the most joyful way for him
to spend his life he really loves doing
that so in a certain way he's no longer
doing it for the money he's doing it
because he loves the whole process of
doing it but
i think that some people get involved in
the world of investing in ways that they
don't enjoy
and they're kind of like distressed debt
workout people
uh
you know i actually i think i take that
back i think most of the people who work
in the highly stressful ends of the
investment business tend to leave once
they've made enough money
and um
but i think that
what i'm trying to say is that to stay
in the investment business in any way
shape or form
if you have enough money and there are
actually other things that you prefer to
do
and the whole point is now you have
financial independence so go do the
things you really love to do
so
and do you find that that balance
actually makes you a better investor you
know being able to
go on you know vacation skiing biking
yeah
that it opens up the freedom to actually
dive deeper into your work
you know i obviously i don't know the
answer to that jeremy because i haven't
tried the alternative
and i think that that that so so i'd
like to believe so but i can't prove it
to you and i don't want to try and prove
it to you
and so you know let we have we have to
if we want to be scientific about it we
have we cannot
um
uh we cannot rule out a hypothesis
that um
doing that
wouldn't that actually if i was uh if i
was more work and less play so to speak
if i was actually tight chaining myself
to the desk and wearing a suit every day
i might have better returns you know
that's that's always a possibility
um but i think that
and i don't know maybe somebody who's an
expert who's an expert in decision
sciences who listens to this
will be able to get back to me with a
good answer but it seems to me that
there's a whole area of decision making
which is around
the fact that we can't live two lives
and so all we can do is pick one of two
choices
you know as as wh orden famous said to
two paths diverse in the woods and i
took the one less traveled and that's
made all the difference i don't think
that's w h order that's robert frost
forgive me
how exactly do we make a choice when two
paths diverge in a wood and we can only
take one which is effectively
the story of our lives
and um you know robert frost
he just says oh take the one less
traveled that's probably not a bad
thing to do i would tell you another
another kind of really good heuristic
that i have not always succeeded in
doing is take the more difficult one
because the easier one you can always
revert to the easier one but it's very
hard to move
from the easier to the more difficult
and so when we go to you know achieving
balance in one's life i don't know
what's
i don't know what's the uh the best
strategy i think that to work hard
earlier in your career
you know to take the risk that you work
too hard but that you you know it's
better to work too hard
and to have overworked yourself in order
to get success than not to have worked
hard enough and try to make that
correction later
but i think that once you get to a
certain point in your life maybe that
flips
and you've got more danger in forcing
yourself into too much
uh too much work and not enough play too
much narrowness not enough looking out
at the world
and i certainly
am experiencing diminishing returns to
financial well-being i mean according to
jordan peterson once you get beyond
sixty thousand dollars in income pr
i don't think i agree with that but at
some point as my father says how many
stakes can a man eat and so if that's
the case
you know another way of putting this and
i hope that i'm i'm making myself clear
enough that i'm not just rambling
um if if we need oxygen to breathe
and at the end of the money at the end
of the money at the end of the day
money is a kind of an oxygen it's
something that facilitates us to be able
to do things
um if we have enough oxygen in our life
imagine jeremy's stick knee has enough
oxygen and i go visit jeremy and what he
does is he shows me how he has more
oxygen than he could breathe in many
different lifetimes
uh you know you'd be like well
you know you just say look at all the
oxygen i got isn't it so great it's like
actually no it's not great what a waste
of time why are you collecting that up
you're never going to use it it doesn't
look pretty just sitting around
so similarly
once you have enough money to live
the person who kind of thinks it's an
ornament in their lives to have more
money than they could ever know what to
do with
is
um it's the same as the guy with too
much oxygen a certain way and if i stop
and i think about people with just crazy
amounts of money
uh who i still respect
it's yes it's not an account for the
money it's an account of what they've
built bill
um
uh jeff bezos you you challenged me and
told me i'm wrong he doesn't walk around
saying look how rich i am if anything he
says look at the amazing company that
i've built look at amazon look at blue
origin look at here the the here's the
change i want to see in the world
similarly we know that warren buffett's
incredibly wealthy but but what we
admire of him for is the company that
he's built
so that's a real thing to do and if
you're a builder of companies then you
know knock yourself out and become bill
gates
uh
jeff bezos or one of those great
business people but if you just wanted
financial independence and what you
really love doing is studying
pure mathematics then you know maybe you
should be spending time doing pure
mathematics
and
i haven't figured out which one of those
i am yet
i would just tell you that
talking about indirect goals
i think that uh and even though i can't
say that my life or the business i have
is particularly good at this
i think partly inspired by john alcan
and partly inspired by sequoia funds
website
i think that i want to sort of get the
sort of use the tagline in my annual
report that says we build great
businesses
and now when i write that in the annual
report what i'm going to have to write
in addition to that somewhere close by
is
dear reader this doesn't mean that we
actually have succeeded in building
great businesses but this is our
aspiration
this is where we're headed this is what
we're trying to do
um and uh
why because because i think that is a
noble and worthy goal
and if you've got enough money
then to have to have your goal is just
being amassing more of it
nobody's going to deny or get upset at
the guy who's short of oxygen in
collecting up oxygen tanks nobody wants
to be short of oxygen but when you got
enough maybe you should think
that is uh i've never quite heard it put
like that and that that really resonated
with me of
how silly that is um
you know i do want to be respectful of
your time um
so
uh
you've given a ton of gold nuggets here
that i will definitely be
you know pondering and reflecting uh on
a walk today
but
you know with everything i guess you
know a lot of the viewers are people in
their 20s to early 30s and i'm curious
if you could just you know very hard to
do and it's it's never
you know it will never be a full
sentence but if you could distill
one lesson
for for people
in their 20s early 30s that
they should maybe think about
as they go off and
you know go into work and trying to
build wealth and
trying to manage a balanced life what
would that piece of advice be
yeah and could i tell you that standing
in one on one leg in one sentence
i know i know yeah exactly actually
something does come to mind so we're in
luck
uh uh and and um
my piece of advice is
that you should
relentlessly
compound goodwill
and so you know we talk a lot about the
power of compounding
charlie munger or not charlie munger i
think it was actually albert einstein
who called it the eighth wonder of the
world
um you know take any number and grow it
at a consistent pace for a long period
of time and it'll turn into a ginormous
number and
you know just a quick example there
warren buffett
there's some amazing statistic in which
we discover that 80 of warren buffett's
net wealth was made in the last 10 years
so over a career that spanned 50 years
and that's just the way compounding
works the numbers start off small and
they get really really big at the very
very end
and
but most of the time it's kind of
indiscernible the person is on a higher
compounding rate you don't see it in any
case we talk a lot about compounding
financial wealth but i think that
one of the most important things that i
learned from uh being around warren
buffett and charlie munger and attending
the berkshire meetings and
being around investors is that we can
compound not just
money we can compound goodwill and so
what does that mean
um
if if you leave if i leave every
interaction
with every single person if i possibly
can
leaving them feeling like they got a
good deal
and it was a worthwhile interaction so
i'm not going to
i'm not gonna take every last penny
i'm not gonna make them feel like you
know they've got to check their hands
see if all five fingers attached after
i've shaken it the opposite i'm gonna
see to it that they make money i see to
it that they do well i see to it that
when they come to a meeting with me they
get more than they ever bargained for
that may be difficult and expensive
because sometimes i'm going to have to
really work hard to make that happen but
if you do that over a lifetime
and i've kind of been doing my best
given you know counting my limitations
but within my limitations i've been
doing my best to do that
probably over the last at least 10 if
not 15 years
i think that the benefits only really
kick in when you've been doing it for
maybe 20 to 25 years so
imagine i'm 55
and probably i'm really gonna start
hitting my stride when i'm 65.
and
the point is that
there's this kind of deep slow long
build to some people's lives
and that happens because they collected
up
um
all of these kind of like aggregation of
marginal gains tiny tiny advantages in
life because people gave them just
they gave to people just a little bit
more so to relentlessly compound
goodwill just to give you an example i
really do think that
warren buffett's kind of addicted to
doing that in his life and i could give
two or three examples that i've
witnessed personally
where the only explanation that i have
for him doing what he did
is that it's a habit of his to try and
do that as often as possible and so if i
look to my and again i'm not going to
try and show it to you but i just
glanced at a holiday card that warren
sent me he's only sent me one holiday
card so it's not like i'm on his annual
holiday card list but this holiday card
is an unusual
holiday card in that it's got a
photograph of warren on the front
uh and he's dressed in the sand no he's
he's next to a santa
and uh it's kind of a quirky card of a
photograph of him in the santa and it's
got a list of things that he wants for
the new year and then warren has has
scrawled on it in a
in a felt tip pen
a message to me where you can clearly
discern the word guy
and this card is the back of the car
jeremy there's nothing on it so it's
clearly designed to be framed
so he has no doubt as to what's going to
happen to that card and then no i
received that card
and of course i framed it it's up on my
wall i received that card
and um the first thing that i say to
myself is
why on earth would warren buffet his
wealth at that point tens of billions of
dollars
write some stupid cards to mr guy spear
whom he met once is never going to
amount to hill of beans in his world
and i think that the best explanation
that i have
is that
he's doing that he's saying this is
going to send guy into 7th heaven
and
it's not that he wants specifically guy
spirit to go and seven into nirvana over
this it's that he wants to live a life
in which he keeps doing that for people
because he knows you know it's a
it's the extension of the thank you
notes
the thank you notes are really just a
little package of joy
delivered in a in a handwritten letter
that arrives on this person's desk or
wherever they are and says
here's a little bit of endorphin kick
for you somebody thought about you and
cares about you
enough that they were willing to write
this note and you're important enough in
the world and you're significant enough
in the world that you are deserving of a
handwritten note
and in a certain sense doing something
like that or other things that warren
has done sort of takes the bar even
higher and so he's doing that
you know thousands of times pr and the
person he is today is the culmination of
so so maya what i would say to
just to bring it back to your your
question is
what should somebody in their 20s do
so my response is someone in their 20s
should start investing in the world
around them in that way in a way that
suits them
but has this
deep and long-term payoffs and they
should start developing the patience to
understand that these payoffs will only
come potentially decades into the future
but they'll be so rich and rewarding
that they do
just to pick up on another point
and i certainly i thought about it
consciously in this way i said i have a
choice of living two lives
in one version of my life i don't write
the thank you notes and we'll see what
happens in another version i do
i cannot run the experiment i have to
pick one of those two paths robert frost
two piles diverged in the wood and even
though i don't know what would have
happened on the other path i'm so
pleased that i chose the path that i did
and i urge every single one of the
listeners to to choose that path
and just one added point is that
what's also so beautiful about that is
that it's non-zero sum
so i'm not urging the reader or the
listener to do anything that will
detract from anybody else that what is
available to anybody else or will
detract from anybody's happiness
or
food to feed them or all those things
the contrary
i think that it has the net effect of
increasing happiness in the world and
i'll before handing you the back to
michael just finish on this point so you
know we have a whole effort here at the
office that's dedicated to helping me
send out all these missives of
joy
and i joke with them and i say look i
don't know what effect this will have on
our lives but we'll certainly have made
the world just a little happier place
and even if it's on account of just that
i'm happy to do it
wow thank you that was
yeah i i really hope everyone tries the
the thank you notes and uh
yeah
i just i really want to thank you for
your time it was a it was amazing to
yeah have a conversation with you and
not just investing but also just
life and philosophy and
i mean again you could say so much of
investing is that
that is the essence of it so
um i'm just yeah very appreciative of
your time and um the advice you you gave
me and and the audience here today
well likewise jeremy i think that um
you know i uh you have a quality to you
which i think benjamin israeli had so
just to tell you the short story
um
some famous lady in british society sat
next to
she sat at a dinner i believe this
actually happened and she was sitting in
between sir isaac newton
and benjamin israeli so so isaac newton
one of the smartest guys of his day
discovered
equations for gravity and other
calculus and all sorts of other
wonderful things and um
benjamin israeli prime minister of the
uk and she came away after and she was
asked about her experience
speaking to those two people
and she said of sir isaac newton she
said well when i was speaking to isaac
newton um i definitely felt i was
speaking to the smartest guy on the
planet and i had no doubt about that
and so her interlocutor asks so well and
how did you feel about talking to
benjamin israeli
and she says well talking to benjamin is
really i felt like i was the smartest
person on the planet
and so you know so isaac newton might
have been super smart but he didn't have
the emotional quotient to make his
conversational partner feel good whereas
benjamin israeli had the emotional the
eq to make his conversational partner
feel absolutely great she felt like she
was the smartest person on the planet so
i think that you have a similar quality
to benjamin's israeli you
you you knew what questions to asked and
you kept quiet and allowed me to ramble
on in a way that made me feel pretty
good that's a very special skill so good
job thank you
if you like that video you need to check
out this video right here on the number
one skill investors need to build wealth
right here i like it when i can make an
investment in a company
and in three or four years i get all my
money
if you're going to take all your
money
and put it into the market today into
the index that's probably
not the best idea